alright so welcome to pax prime and what
is there to do at PAX Prime when you
have no sleep whatsoever you pull an
all-nighter you come to the sony booth
and I figured Sony would bring it to
Sony had the three things that I wanted
to see here one of which is PlayStation
all-stars battle royale now you know I
did a video about PlayStation all-stars
battle royale when it was announced and
there was a lot of speculation is it as
super smash brothers ripoff is it not I
will say this if it is a super smash
brothers ripoff it's the coolant I am
down to play super smash brothers ripoff
when my friends and I were playing it we
got done we looked at each other we were
like let's play another round this
because it was fun as hell I mean the
one thing you have to you have to get
used to in this one is that it's not
percentage of life like super smash
brothers super-stretch brothers you can
get to 200 five percent and you can you
can stay in if you're really good enough
but in this one it's a life bar once
your life bar is done it's gone but I
got to say when your crate else and you
pull out those special moves yeah you
kick some ass unless someone use a sly
cooper and beat the living piss out of
you which actually happened do you beat
my ass with Sly Cooper I was Kratos only
in battle royale
man the lighting is just impossible in
here and I'm not even lying eye shadow
face totally
another game of wine at checkout was god
of war ascension again you played god of
war 3 you're like ah cool fulfillments
there's no need for another god of war
they announce another god of war and
you're like what to think of it so i
actually played god of war ascension i
gotta say it's a solid game i mean
everything you liked about god of war 3
is in it he has new moves they
incorporated the new kick-butt encircles
a new kick button opens the door for a
whole new set of combos it's violent
it's gritty and graphically speaking it
is the most impressive god of war I've
seen when you see I like yeah but I
guess they come a long way in just a
couple short ears for playstation 3
technology but it looks really really
impressive who's not going to get that
what God of War fan is not going to get
god of war ascension so far it has my
stamp of approval
are so a couple of cool games for our
first video for pax and only on my
channel will you get the cartoon fun of
PlayStation all-stars battle royale mix
with the total death and carnage of god
of war but hey that's how i roll on my
channel one thing i forgot to talk about
was actually the cross compatibility
with PlayStation all-stars battle royale
I was playing the PS Vita version my
friends were playing the ps3 version and
you can actually cross play and fight
each other and it works perfectly on
there and they told me here at the sony
booth if you buy the playstation 3
version of PlayStation all-stars battle
royale you get a downloadable version of
the PS Vita version absolutely free and
if you saw my PSP two videos that's what
I loved about it that's how PS Vita is
supposed to work so I'm glad they're
really stepping up to that play I have a
lot more videos coming to you from pax
from this place is enormous and I'll try
they get to as much as I can but odds
are things are going to slip through the
cracks oh please tell me what you want
me to talk about I'll try to get to it
enormous ass place that's how we do it
in Seattle we do a big